PROFESSOR: So the topic of
today's lecture, as you can
see from the title,
is liberty.
And the best way to get a sense
of the project in which
we will find ourselves engaged
today is to contrast the
opening pages of Rawls' Theory
of Justice with the opening
pages of Nozick's Anarchy,
State, and Utopia.
So you'll recall that when we
were reading the Rawls--
for some reason the remote is
not working, that's a pity but
there we go--
you'll recall that when we were
reading the Rawls, Rawls
began his text by speaking of
justice as the first virtue of
social institutions.
It plays the role with regard
to the legitimacy of an
institution that truth plays
with regard to the legitimacy
of a system of thought.
Each person, says Rawls,
"possesses an inviolability
founded on justice that even
the welfare of society as a
whole cannot override." For
this reason, says Rawls
famously in these opening pages,
"justice denies that
the loss of freedom for some
is made right by a greater
good shared by others"
So Rawls is concerned with and
inviolability of humanity
based on a notion of justice.
Nozick is also concerned with
a kind of inviolability.
But rather than seeing the core
of that inviolability as
lying in some notion of justice
he sees it as lying in
a notion of rights.
So he says in the opening of
the preface, the first
sentence which you
read for today.
"Individuals have rights and
there are things that no
person or group may do to them
without violating those
rights." And he goes on to say
that "the minimal state
limited to the narrow functions
of protection
against force, theft, fraud, the
enforcement of contracts
and so on is the most extensive
state that can be justified.
Any state more extensive than
the minimal state violates
people's rights."
So there's something
extraordinarily interesting
going on in this
pair of works.
Both of them are concerned with
the fundamental question
which we first encountered in
the context of Hobbes: how
could it be that it's legitimate
to have a state?
Both of them are concerned with
structuring the state in
such a way that it doesn't
violate that which is
perceived as being on their
picture as inviolable.
But they differ profoundly in
what sort of state they end up
calling legitimate.
Perhaps because at the core of
Rawls's picture lies the
notion of justice, whereas at
the core of Nozick's picture
lies the notion of rights.
So what I want to do in today's
lecture is to contrast
some of the themes, which we
encountered last lecture in
the context of Rawls' Theory
of Justice by looking at a
particular famous chapter of his
colleague Robert Nozick's
work, Anarchy, State,
and Utopia.
Even from the brief selections
that you read from these two
works, the differences between
them should have
been evident to you.
They were written a mere
three years apart.
Rawls' Theory of Justice
was published in 1971.
Nozick's Anarchy, State,
and Utopia three
years later in 1974.
Rawls and Nozick at the time had
offices down the hall from
one another.
But Rawls' work, as you will
feel, is part of a major
philosophical project.
It's extraordinarily
self reflective.
Rawls is in his middle age
when he writes it.
And he's been thinking about
these questions for decades.
Nozick's book is an
extraordinarily insightful
response to Rawls, as well
as being a positive
formulation of a view.
But it's not a work with the
gravitas of Theory of Justice.
It was written when Nozick
was quite young.
He was in his early 30s.
And it's important to know that
although these works are
typically paired in philosophy
courses-- (If you took-- or
are taking--
Moral Foundations of Politics
or an introductory political
theory course, you will get
these two books paired
together.),--
Theory of Justice is, if you
look at its citation index,
more than three times more
influential, if that's the
measure, than Anarchy,
State, and Utopia.
So Theory of Justice Google
Scholar citation is roughly
30,000 whereas Anarchy, State,
and Utopia is roughly 10,000.
These are extraordinarily high
numbers in philosophy.
Those of you who have
encountered works in other
domains of philosophy, for
example Kripke's Naming and
Necessity, written at about
this time, its citation
numbers are about half that of
Anarchy, State, and Utopia,
about 5,000.
So what I want you to take home
from this is the idea
that these are enormously
influential works with
consequences far beyond academic
philosophy, but that
they differ in their tone.
So Anarchy, State, and Utopia
is an attempt to defend the
minimal state from two different
kinds of objections.
In the first part of the work,
Nozick defends the state
against the position
of anarchy.
He argues that a minimal state
is justified, that it's not
the case that it's a violation
of people's rights to have
basic enforcement of laws,
police and the sort of
fundamental things that are
required for the basic
stability of getting out of
Hobbes's state of nature.
The second part of the book,
with which our reading was
concerned, defends the minimal
state against a more
maximalist picture.
And in that part of the book,
Nozick defends the rights of
people to liberty in two
kinds of domains.
The first is that he defends
people's rights to enter into
almost any sort of contract
that they would like.
He defends, for example, the
right of people under certain
conditions to contract
themselves into slavery.
He defends, in other contexts,
the right to have an
enforceable blackmail
contract.
That's not the part of
the book which we
read excerpts from.
The part of the book that we
read excerpts from, and to
which the remainder of lecture
will be devoted, is Nozick's
discussion of our relation
to property.
So what Nozick tries to do in
the famous seventh chapter of
Anarchy, State, and Utopia is
to articulate a notion of
justice in holdings--
that is, justice with respect
to property--
that provides a principled
explanation of the relation
among the three different kinds
of concerns that one has
in asking about whether it's
legitimate for a person to own
a piece of property.
The first is the question of
justice in acquisition.
Under what conditions--
when I initially
come to acquire
something, say a tomato--
is my acquisition of it such
that my ownership of the
object is in keeping with the
conditions of justice?
And we'll talk about Nozick's
views on justice in
acquisition in a minute.
The second question that Nozick
is concerned with here
is the question of justice
in transfer.
So he's concerned with the
question, if I have an object
and I wish to transfer
possession of that object to
you, under what conditions
is that transfer
justice-preserving?
And finally, Nozick is concerned
with the question of
rectification of injustice.
So suppose I own something which
you illegitimately take
from me, under what conditions
and how do I reclaim
possession of that object?
Nozick's argument is that we can
say everything that needs
to be said about justice
in holdings --
everything that needs to be said
about the distribution of
property in a society
that doesn't violate
people's rights --
by appeal to an inductive
definition
that runs as follows.
He says, "If a person acquires
a holding in keeping with the
principle of justice in
acquisition, the person, p, is
entitled to the holding." So, if
I come to own something in
a way that is legitimate,
rule-following, my owning of
that object is in keeping with
the rules of justice.
The second clause is an
induction clause.
"If a person acquires a holding,
in keeping with the
principle of justice in
transfer, from somebody who
was entitled--
either as a result of a transfer
or as the result of
an initial acquisition--
to hold that object, then the
person is entitled to hold
that object."
And finally, Nozick has
a closure clause.
"No one is entitled to a holding
except by repeated
applications of one and two."
Now those of you who have taken
mathematics are familiar
with this sort of definition.
If I wanted to provide an
inductive definition of the
natural numbers, I might begin
by saying "one is a member the
set of natural numbers."
That's my base clause.
I then add, "if anything is a
member of the set of natural
numbers, then that plus one is a
numbers." And then I put in
place some sort of closure
condition such that "the natural
numbers," for example,
"are all and only those things
that satisfy the first and
second clause."
So the picture that Nozick is
providing us with here is one
that gives us a certain
kind of closed system.
So let's see how it works
in a particular case.
Nozick stresses that when you
make use of the principles
that he's articulated here, what
matters is the process
not the outcome.
So suppose I come to
possess a tomato.
It makes all the difference in
the world, on Nozick's view
what the actual process
by which I came to
possess that object is.
If, for example, there was a
garden down the road from me,
which I didn't own, where a
beautiful tomato sat, and I
took that tomato without
permission, my possession of
that tomato is illegitimate.
Hmm.
Even if there is an alternative
process--
a hypothetical one--
which I didn't in fact engage
in whereby I could have come
to have that tomato
legitimately.
If a thief takes your property,
says Nozick, it
doesn't make his possession of
your property legitimate even
if you could have voluntarily
given it to him.
Moreover, says Nozick, if I
come to possess something
illegitimately and I transfer
it to you--
even by legitimate means--
it retains its illegitimate
status.
So the picture that Nozick is
presenting in his discussion
of holdings is one with the
following characteristics.
Justice in holdings--
and this will be important for
his critique of Rawls--
justice in holdings
is historical.
It depends on what actually
happened.
In particular, if something is
owned as result of an unjust
acquisition, it produces
an unjust holding.
If something is owned as
a result of an unjust
acquisition plus a just
transfer, it still produces an
unjust holding.
If something is owned as the
results of a just acquisition
and an unjust transfer, it
produces an unjust holding.
And if something is owned
as a result of an unjust
acquisition and an unjust
transfer, it's not that these
two injustices cancel
one another out.
Rather we have, again,
an unjust holding.
It's under two conditions
that holdings are
just on Nozick's picture.
The first is if it's a
straightforward just
acquisition.
And the second is if there's a
just acquisition followed by
one or more just transfers.
So far this isn't getting Nozick
very far in terms of a
critique of Rawls.
But the next step will allow you
to see how this notion of
justice in property does work
on the Nozick picture.
What Nozick goes on to say is
that the holdings of a person
are just if he's entitled to
them by the principles of
justice in acquisition and
transfer or in imperfect
situations by the principle
of rectification.
That is, it is a necessary
condition on justice in
holding that they have been
acquired through one
of these two steps.
But it is also a sufficient
condition.
If each person's holdings are
just then there are no more
questions to be asked about the
aggregation of holdings.
If each person's holdings are
just, then the distribution of
holdings is just.
So we'll see when we get to
justice in transfer how it is
that this notion, both of taking
historical properties
as the relevant ones in
determining justice and in
taking the inductive property
holding characterization as
necessary and sufficient for
justice in holdings, how it is
that those pair of things
provides Nozick with the
leverage to criticize the
outlook to which all of you
from behind the veil of
ignorance last class-- or the
majority of you from
behind the veil of
ignorance last class--
seems to think was what
justice mandated.
That is, Nozick takes from this
very simple picture an
argument, which from his
perspective renders
illegitimate any sort
of centralized
redistribution of resources.
So you remember, in order to
evaluate Nozick's inductive
definition that we need to know
what it is that he thinks
justice in acquisition
involves.
And what it is that he thinks
justice in transfer involves.
So the discussion of justice
in acquisition is a rather
complicated portion of the text
that I had you read for
today's class.
What Nozick does is to make
appeal to the work of the 17th
century philosopher John Locke,
whose Second Treatise
on Government begins
its discussion
of property as follows.
Locke writes, "Though the
Earth and all inferior
creatures be common to all
men, yet every man has a
property in his own person.
This nobody has any right
to but himself.
The labor of his body and the
work of his hands we may say
are properly his."
So on Locke's picture of the
state of nature there's a
world out there unowned.
We're setting aside a set
of concerns about
whether this picture--
that the Earth and all inferior
creatures belong in
any principled sense to human
beings-- and rather looking at
what it is that Locke's argument
for the justice in
acquisition clause involves.
So Locke says, the world out
there of objects doesn't
belong to anybody.
But what each person does have
is the rights to his or her
own body and, in particular,
possession, ownership rights
over his labor.
So, says Locke, "Whatsoever he
removes out of the state that
nature hath provided and left in
it he hath mixed his labor
with and joined it to something
that is his own and
thereby makes it his property."
Concluding, "It
being by him removed from the
common state nature placed it
in, it hath by this labor
something annexed to it that
excludes the common right
of other men.
For this labor being the
unquestionable property of the
laborer, no man but he can have
a right to what that is
once joined to, at least when
there is enough, and as good,
left in common for others."
So Nozick takes from
this discussion
of Locke two things.
The first thing he takes is the
idea that what justice in
acquisition involves is a
certain kind of mixing of what
is one's own, one's labor,
with something that is
previously unowned --
potential property in
the state of nature.
And although Nozick has all
sorts of criticisms about the
unclarity of this
characterization.
He says, for example, "If I
go to Mars and sweep off a
portion of the planet,
have I thereby
claimed just that portion?
Have I claimed the entire
planet of Mars?
Have I claimed all of the
planets that lie beyond it?"
He also asks why it is that
mixing one's labor with
something should lead to
possession of the object
rather than the losing
of one's labor.
But ultimately he's willing to
accept that something like the
Lockean picture is going
to underlie justice in
acquisition.
What worries him, and what he
devotes the bulk of the
selection that you read for last
night to, is this concern
about whether what he calls the
Lockean Proviso, the idea
that in order for acquisition
to be legitimate there needs
to be enough and as good left
in common for others.
Whether Proviso is frequently
violated.
Because if that Proviso were
frequently violated then
justice in acquisitions
wouldn't be simple and
straightforward in the way that
Nozick wants it to be.
So the basic structure of the
argument that you read--
and I'll run through it in
more detail in a minute--
the basic structure of the
argument that you read in the
context of Nozick's discussion
of Locke runs as follows.
Locke has a reasonable picture
of what acquisition of
property involves.
We need to fuss with it around
the edges but I'm not going to
worry about that, says Nozick.
What I am going to worry about
is whether this notion of
there being "enough and as
good left in common for
others" is going to undercut
the whole Lockean picture.
So what's the idea look like?
Suppose that four of us come
upon a field of previously
unclaimed cows.
And that one of us claims
four of the cows.
And then a second of us claims
six of the cows and a third of
us claims the remaining
six cows.
Has the Lockean Proviso
been violated?
Nozick's first worry, which he
calls the unzipping worry, is
that perhaps it's not just the
blue character who took the
last six cows who's violated
the Lockean Proviso.
Perhaps the yellow character,
in limiting the blue
character, has violated it and
the red character, in limiting
the yellow character by limiting
the blue character,
has somehow violated the
Lockean Proviso.
Nozick says no.
The fact that the red
character's activities limited
the yellow character's
activities, if we took into
consideration the blue
character's activities, is not
sufficient to render red or
yellow in violation of the
Lockean Proviso.
So that's step one.
But we still might wonder
whether the blue character has
violated the Lockean Proviso.
After all, how could he have
left as much and as good for
our fourth character--
pink over here--
if pink isn't in a position
to get any cows?
Nozick's answer is that in
taking on ownership of objects
and mixing one's labor with
them, typically what the
subject does is to increase
the value of
those objects for all.
So red, from his four
cows, might produce
one gallon of milk.
And yellow might produce two and
blue might produce three.
As a result, pink--
though he doesn't have
access to the cows--
is better off.
And, says Nozick, the Lockean
Proviso has not been violated.
So what Nozick says in
particular, is he asks whether
the situation of persons who
are unable to appropriate--
there being no more acceptable
and unowned objects--
is their situation worsened
by a system of allowing
appropriation and private
property?
And the answer he gives
is a resounding no.
For exactly the sort of reasons
that we're familiar
with from our Hobbes case --
the idea that there is a kind of
social contract that kicks
in that allows everybody
to benefit.
And also because Nozick firmly
believes that individual
ownership brings with it a
particular kind of efficiency.
So Nozick's worry, which was:
is the Lockean Proviso going
to knock my theory out of the
water such that I can't get
the base clause of my inductive
argument going?
Nozick's conclusion is that
appropriation of private
property satisfies the intent
behind the "enough and as good
left over" Proviso.
But, he is careful to point
out, this is not based on
utilitarian reasoning.
It's not based on a utilitarian
justification of property.
Nozick--
like Rawls--
is concerned with articulating
a rights based theory.
And so, like Rawls, doesn't
allow trade-offs
of rights for utilities.
So the argument about the
original acquisition of
property runs as follows.
Nozick says, I have the right to
do everything that doesn't
harm others and the right
to do only what
doesn't harm others.
My rights begin and end in
their restrictions and
permissions with consideration
of what brings harm to others.
Violating the Lockean Proviso,
if I managed to do that, would
leave others worse off than they
would have been otherwise
and consequently would
harm them.
As a consequence, says Nozick,
I don't have the right to
violate the Lockean Proviso.
If, as a matter of fact, my
original acquisition of
property doesn't leave as much
and as good for others, then
my original acquisition was
not an instance of just
property ownership.
But, says Nozick, except
in very rare cases--
he calls them conditions of
catastrophe or desert island
limitations--
acquiring property doesn't
violate the Lockean Proviso or
harm others.
And the argument for this
sub-clause, this sub-argument,
is a utility- based argument.
It's on the grounds of utility
that I get the premise that
except in rare cases acquiring
property doesn't violate the
Lockean Proviso.
But the fundamental argument, I
have the right to do all and
only what doesn't harm others.
Except in very rare cases
acquiring property does not
violate the Lockean Proviso
and harm others.
That one, plus four, is
sufficient to give us the
conclusion that except in very
rare cases I have the right to
acquire property.
So that is, by way of
exposition, of what I
understand to have been a fairly
difficult part of the
assigned text.
So let's move now to an easier
segment of the text.
So as we noted, Nozick provides
his defense of the
base clause by appeal to Locke's
notion of original
acquisition of property and
defends that against the
potential objection--
the Lockean Proviso
objection--
in providing a clearer sense
of what that amounts to.
In many ways the most famous
part of the text comes in
Nozick's defense of the
induction clause.
So in defending the induction
clause -- which, remember,
says that if P acquires H, in
keeping with the principle of
justice in transfer, from
somebody already entitled,
that P is entitled to H --
Nozick is concerned with
what justice in
transfer amounts to.
So he begins by distinguishing
something that should be
familiar to all of you from your
readings of Mill and Kant
earlier this semester.
He distinguishes between
principles that are
historical--
that is that tell us that
whether a distribution is just
depends upon how
it came about.
That is, what we are concerned
with when we are concerned
about justice is a question
of process.
And he contrasts those with
what he calls end-result
principles where, whether a
distribution is just depends
upon how things are
distributed.
So you'll remember that when
we were reading Kant and
trying to determine whether an
action counted as moral or
morally praiseworthy, Kant was
concerned about the process by
which that action
was carried out.
Mill, by contrast, was concerned
with outcome.
Nozick goes on, in the opening
parts of chapter seven that we
read, to provide a defense of
historical principles and to
argue that one consequence of
that will be that we can never
judge the justice of a society
by looking at how its goods
are distributed.
So, he points out, it has been
typical in the articulation of
theories of justice, to claim
that a society is just if
goods are distributed according
to some sort of
independently specifiable
criterion.
For example, distribute goods
according to the moral merit
of those who receive them, or
according to the intelligence
of those who receive them or
according to the effort that
individuals put in, or according
to their need for
the objects that
you distribute.
Nozick points out that people
want their society to look
just. And they also want their
society to be just. But in
asking their society to look
just, Nozick thinks they make
a mistake if they take pattern
as a way of determining
legitimate outcome.
Must the look of justice, asks
Nozick, reside in a resulting
pattern, which we can specify
independently and in advance
rather than in the underlying
generating principles?
And to think about this, it's
helpful to help ourselves to a
three-way distinction that
John Rawls makes in the
context of Theory of Justice.
Rawls distinguishes between
three kinds of procedural
justice there.
The first is a notion
of what he calls
perfect procedural justice.
This is a case where we have an
independent criterion for
what the right result of our
act will be and a procedure
that is certain to give
us that result.
So, for example, if I'm trying
to divide a cake, of which all
of us want pieces, there's an
independent criterion for the
right result.
Namely each of us gets a piece
of exactly the same size.
And there's a sure procedure for
arriving at that result.
What I do is I allow one person
to slice and that is
the person who chooses his piece
last. So long as he's in
a position to make precise
cuts, the result of this
procedure will always give
us what it is that we
independently specified as
the outcome we sought.
We want equal slices, we have
an independent criterion for
the right result, and we
have a sure procedure.
He who slices chooses last.
By contrast, in most situations,
what we find
ourselves in is a condition
where our only choice is what
Rawls calls imperfect
procedural justice.
Where we have an independent
criterion for the right result
but the procedure that
we have for achieving
that result is imperfect.
So for example, in the legal
system we have a goal of
convicting all and only those
who are guilty of a crime.
We have a clear sense of what
the right result will be.
But though we have a procedure
which presumably does a good
deal better than chance, it is
undeniable that on occasion
the guilty go free.
And likewise undeniable
that on occasion the
innocent are convicted.
The third kind of procedural
justice is what Rawls calls
pure procedural justice.
This is a case where we have
no independent way of
specifying the result.
And what we do is we adopt a
procedure by which we will
carry out in real time, in
actuality, some sort of
distribution.
And as the result of having
followed that procedure,
whichever distribution
arises is fair.
So gambling has this
structure.
There is a rule that we have. We
all pays our money and then
we takes our chances.
And whatever distribution of
outcomes results from that is
legitimate.
Nozick's claim is that the
distribution of property in a
society ought to be understood
as subject, not to some sort
of perfect or imperfect
procedural justice.
That is, there's no independent
criterion for how
it is that goods ought to be
distributed across people.
Rather, it's simply a matter of
living historically through
a process whereby things are
required in just fashion and
transferred in just fashion,
and seeing how it is that
things distribute themselves.
So in contrast to some sort of
pattern picture, Marx has this
idea, from each according to his
ability to each according
to his needs.
That's an idea that there's an
independent criterion of how
things should be distributed.
Nozick provides, in contrast,
this rather complicated
articulation: "from each
according to what he chooses
to do and roughly to each as
they are chosen." That is,
however things distribute
themselves, as long as the
process is fair, will
end up being fair.
And this gives rise to Nozick's
famous argument that
liberty upsets patterns.
So Nozick asks us to imagine
a world in which all of our
friends from behind the veil
of ignorance are given
whatever equal share you
give them in your fair
distribution.
So each of them ends up
with a piggy bank of
the appropriate size.
But all of them, says Nozick,
are basketball fans and they
choose to take a quarter of
their own money and to deposit
it in the bank account
of Wilt Chamberlain.
And so do their friends and so
do their friends and so do
their friends until, as a result
of people freely doing
what a legitimate transfer
permits, Wilt Chamberlain
comes to have so much money
that his piggy bank gets
blurry on the slide.
He's that extraordinarily
wealthy.
Now Nozick takes the Wilt
Chamberlain example to have
two implications.
The first is a descriptive
implication.
The general point, he says,
illustrated by the Wilt
Chamberlain example is that
no end-state principle or
distribution pattern principle
of justice can be continuously
realized without continuous
interference in people's lives.
Any favored pattern will be
transformed into an unfavored
pattern by the principle --
by people exchanging goods and
services with other people or
giving things to other people,
things that the transferers
are entitled to under the
favored distribution pattern.
To maintain a pattern, one must
either interfere with the
process of transferring
resources, or interfere in
such a way that one takes away
from somebody who has
legitimately acquired their
pile of quarters and
redistribute that.
To maintain a pattern, says
Nozick, one must either
interfere to stop people from
transferring resources
as they wish to.
Or interfere to take from them
resources that others chose to
transfer to them.
So that's the descriptive
implication of the Wilt
Chamberlain example.
There's also a normative
implication of the Wilt
Chamberlain example.
Nozick says this, look if D1,
the initial distribution where
each of our characters from
behind the veil of ignorance
had their piggy bank, D1 was
a just distribution.
And people voluntarily moved
from D1 to D2, the one where
Wilt Chamberlain ended up with
the large amount of quarters.
Transferring parts of their
shares that they were given
under D1, isn't D2 also just?
If the people were entitled to
dispose of the resources to
which they were entitled under
D1 one, didn't this include
their being entitled to give to,
or exchange it with Wilt
Chamberlain?
Can anyone else complain
on grounds of justice?
Each other person, says Nozick,
already has his
legitimate share under D1 and
after someone transfers
something to Wilt Chamberlain,
their shares are not changed.
So the descriptive claim is that
liberty will inevitably
upset patterns.
And the normative claim is that
in so doing, no injustice
has occurred.
I'm going to close with two
reasons that one might think
that this argument doesn't
work as cleanly as Nozick
would think.
The first we've encountered
already, which is that many
more situations have the
structure of the problem of
the commons than one might
antecedently realize.
And it's not always the case
that individual transactions
between pairs of people don't
carry with them third-party
consequences.
The second is that it is
sometimes the case that
distributions of resources
across individuals in unequal
ways produces violations of
the sorts of freedoms that
Nozick wants to defend.
So suppose we start out with two
groups of people, each of
whom have roughly similar
amounts of money.
And they send their children to
school with one another and
share the same set
of teachers.
Suppose that one of those
groups, through legitimate
transfers from D1 to D2, comes
to possess a much larger
amount of money and create
another school where they send
their children and where they
hire the teachers who were the
most gifted.
It may become the case that
simply as the result of people
having engaged in behavior
that involved a series of
independently legitimate
transfers, the situation that
results may impede the freedom
of these children to become
citizens of the sort
whose rights
Nozick wishes to defend.
So it's 11:20 now.
And we'll finish up today's
lecture here.
And move next lecture to finish
up with six discussion
of justice in holdings and to
think about that in the
context of some work in
social psychology.